[Music]
this is a shot that I always liked this
low angle looking through the Lions legs
it seemed very very haunting and this
was a scene that we that we had in for a
long long time and it's a Buffalo birth
something that's quite extraordinary to
film actually and that's why we had it
in it was really interesting to us and
it's a wonderful delicate birth in many
ways because you don't see too much of a
go but we eventually decided to take it
out largely because this is a film about
the lost lands and in particular muddy
tower character and not so much about
the Buffalo so we didn't really need
people to get to know the individual
Buffalo's as much as we wanted to have
them stay focused on the line